it makes sense politically rationally
electoral II to gain political power by
saying all sorts of terrible things
about immigrant groups and then you're
in power but at a certain point the math
doesn't work out what is the classic
gangster film scarface the Dublin
musical romance once and the French
coming-of-age film Samia have in common
they're all stories of human beings
coping with their transition to a new
home country in very different ways and
their situations are all representative
stories of the case studies at the
center of Joel fet sirs new book open
borders and international migration
policy Fetzer a professor of political
science at Pepperdine University
examines three cases of massive and at
times nearly unrestricted immigration
made famous in the movies
the influx of Central European
immigrants to Ireland in the early 2000s
as portrayed in the film once the flood
of Algerians into Marseille in the wake
of the Algerian war is seen in the
French film Samia I always know one day
I'm coming here United States and the
Cubans who ended up in South Florida
after Castro is purging of the so-called
scum of Cuban society some results of
which are memorably portrayed in
Scarface Fetzer sat down with us to
discuss with these three natural
experiments in mass migration tell us
about the arguments for and against
opening our borders now open borders
itself is kind of a politically
contentious term what does that term
mean to you basically getting rid of not
necessarily inspection but restrictions
on migration so all the blocking would
have to do with safety concerns and
disease screenings rather than some sort
of quota based on which country they're
coming right so I mean I think an open
borders policy would get rid of the idea
of restricting people because we don't
like your culture or your religion or
the color of your skin or your skill
level or something like that and talk
about some of the common arguments
immigrants take local jobs and they
drive down wages did you find that to be
true when you looked at these exams in
these three cases I actually didn't find
those effects in general so across the
board there were no significant drops in
wages and there were no significant
increases in the unemployment rate for
natives partly this book is a
replication across different countries
and across different types of kind of
social and economic phenomena of a
classic study that David Carr dim and he
found that in the Mario case which in
some ways the sort of the most extreme
case you have almost a hundred thousand
people coming over night the labor force
increases almost overnight by seven
percent what he found was really there
was no effect on wages and the labor
market so it suggests that really the
labor market concerns are not well
founded at all at least in these these
three cases that I studied so another
argument is that immigrants are a drain
on public resources they use the welfare
system they crowd the schools is there
any merit to that argument that they're
a drain on public service they found
hear that at least after you control for
sort of intergovernmental transfer so
especially from the national level down
to the the local level you don't really
have negative financial effects in some
cases they're even positive effects
especially in Dublin after the Eastern
Europeans especially polish migrants
migrants came the tax coffers seemed to
increase and so they had a larger budget
surplus one negative effect that you did
find in the Miami case was a slight
boost in the homicide rate and I believe
you found some other boosts in
burglaries and some of the other cases
we do have comparable statistics for all
three of the cities and statistically
significantly there was an increase in
the burglary rate now that's the
burglary rate what we don't know exactly
who the burglars were and who the
victims were so certainly in the
Marseilles case we have anecdotal
evidence that the victims were the
immigrants themselves and it was the
natives who were burglarizing the
migrants so that's not exactly what a
lot of anti-immigrant politicians think
of when they say that you know it's
going to cause a crime problem there was
a very significant increase in the
homicide rate in Miami only so I think
what was going on in the Miami case was
that Castro actually did in certain
cases go and try to get rid of what he
viewed as undesirables from his society
so in a famous speech and some
editorials in grandma he calls in
escoria right or the scums luisana kind
of worms there were cases certainly that
he let them directly out of the jails
forced them into the boats force the
families the Cuban families from from
Miami to take them along with their
family members and then once they got
into Miami they did you know bad things
Donald Trump has explicitly drawn a
connection between immigrations coming
from our southern border from Mexico and
Central American countries to that
mariel boatlift are we facing a Scarface
type situation on our southern border
right now Donald Trump is not the best
statistician in the world I would argue
and if you look at the recent statistics
basically since the Great Recession you
haven't had net migration from nex
go into the United States certainly
there are mexicans who come but there
have been more mexican so we're leaving
or deciding to stay at home for
demographic and economic reasons what is
causing a lot of migration now is
Central America and that's places like
when notice where the state is having
very difficult times competing with
other sort of violent organizations
especially drug cartels in that country
and so that's causing unbearable
violence including for children say a 12
or 13 year old who's being forced out of
his or her neighborhood in Tegucigalpa
because of the violence that's not the
same person as kind of a 25 year old
who's already from you know Havana who's
already done two or three hits right the
very different type of person and
overall if you look at the most rigorous
quantitative studies they don't find
overall that immigration causes an
increase in the crime there's tension in
certain European countries because of
for instance a lot of Muslim immigration
and they feel like their cities are
becoming something that they weren't
before is that a legitimate fear and is
it something that's this happened before
I found using a lot of public survey
data from the US and from Europe that
people's attitudes are rooted just as
much in sort of cultural fear or the
fear that their culture is going to be
kind of unrespectable it's not going to
be seen as prestigious as compared to
some of the immigrant cultures right
this goes back like the United States
all the way you know to Jefferson's time
right so the you know the people who
voted for Jefferson's with a more
scotch-irish or in late eighteen
hundreds you have lots of you know
beer-drinking German Catholics or Irish
Catholics and they're seen as a big
threat to the Protestants in English and
so on who were here before so if it's
these deeply rooted cultural anxieties
as you say that stretch all the way back
to almost the beginning of the Republic
is there any hope for a political turn
back towards liberalisation of
immigration let alone open borders what
tends to happen is that the height of
xenophobia at least against a particular
group say the Chinese in 1880's in
California the west coast and so on
politically disempowers that point it
makes sense politically rationally
totally to gain political power by
saying all sorts of terrible things
about immigrant groups and then you're
in power but that at a certain point the
math doesn't work out look at what
happened to Pete Wilson in this state
right Pete Wilson the early 1990s
arguably scapegoated Latino immigrants
people coming from especially Mexico he
was able to get those largely angler
votes non-latino votes in California and
he was put back into the governor's
office in Sacramento but in the long run
arguably destroy the republican party in
the state and so what happens is that
you get this wave of xenophobia that
gets the point where targets a group and
then that group eventually gained
political power so I think in the long
run yes I think you know as the US says
immigrant students become more and more
diverse and we have more and more groups
in the United States or first second
third generation immigrants they will
become much more pro-immigrant
politically empowered and that will lead
politicians in the long run at least two
to stop scapegoating them Joel Fetzer
thank you very much for your time thank
you it's my pleasure for a reason TV I'm
Zak why smaller